[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to channel awesome
orbit report your source for everything
happening around the world in pop
culture and entertainment news i'm
heather ruse and this is your news for
Monday May 28th obviously today I'm
flying solo get it I'm sorry anyway hey
um this week there was a ton of casting
news announced first of all we now know
who's going to be playing adult Ben for
its chapter two he's gonna be played by
Jay Ryan who is on CW's Beauty and the
Beast and also on Mary kills people so
that means now we only have one member
of the losers Club who is not cast so
Mike is the only person now for a
chapter - who has not been cast let me
know in the comments below who you think
would be a good idea of good person to
play Mike in it chapter 2 also this week
John wick chapter 3 made some major
casting announcements first of all
Angelica Houston is going to be joining
the cast she's going to be playing the
director so we're assuming that she's
going to be playing the director of the
high table Assassin's Guild they also
announced that Asia Kate Dillon is going
to be playing the adjudicator of the
high table I mean you may know her from
orange is the new black or billions so
it seems like they're definitely going
to be they've been casting some people
now within the high table Assassin's
Guild so that's gonna be playing a huge
part in Chapter three Halle Berry is
also going to be playing the female lead
and simply all we know about her is that
her name is going to be Sophia that's it
that's all we know about her Elm and she
is going to be playing a character that
is opposite of John wick so I'm assuming
she has a huge role in it which I think
sounds exciting and interesting I mean
Halle Berry does action well so I'm
hoping that
has some good chemistry with Keanu
Reeves and this is going to be good news
for the film they also announced that
Laurence Fishburne and Ian McShane will
be reprising their roles as well and
again that's coming out next May so we
got some time to think about it but I'm
excited about this movie and I'm hoping
that these casting this casting news is
only good things also this week speaking
of action movies Liam Neeson is going to
be cast it has been cast now and the Men
in Black spin-off so he's going to be
joining Chris Hemsworth and Tessa
Thompson in the new men and men and
black spin-off we don't know anything
still about Chris Hemsworth or Tessa
Thompson's characters but what we do
know is that Liam Neeson is going to be
playing the director of the London
division of men in black so I'm assuming
that a lot of this then is going to be
taking place in London um since he is
the London director of the men in black
organization and we can see more of
that's coming out on June 14 2019 so
still a ways away I'm assuming they
haven't quite started the filming
process yet also this week the HBO
Watchmen miniseries basically dropped
their whole entire cast list but
interestingly interestingly enough what
they didn't do is tell us who any of
these people are playing so there's been
a ton of speculation flying around on
the internet about who these people are
playing we do know that the lead is
going to be played by actress Regina
King so a lot of the speculation is that
she's going to be playing Angela Abraham
she's also going to be accompanied by
Don Johnson and there's no idea I have
no idea who he could be playing Tim
Blake Nelson and Louie goes at junior
who people have been speculating maybe
playing old man and Adelaide Clemens who
people have been speculating maybe
playing pirate Jenny
and then lastly Andrew Howard now you
may be thinking with some of these
speculations where are the
characters of watchmen that we know like
comedian or dr. Manhattan well this
week's showrunner Damon Lindelof went to
Instagram and revealed a little bit more
about what exactly we can expect from
this miniseries basically what he said
is that it's not going to be a direct
adaptation in the letter he was that he
posted on Instagram he basically said
that he wanted to respect the fact that
alan moore has said that watchmen is
made for a specific medium and that
medium is comics so instead of retelling
that story again he wants to create
something that uses the watchmen series
as a base and kind of goes off of that
so in this world the events of watchmen
have happened like the comedians died
all of that has all happened it's just
that now this series is going to be what
he's calling a modern retelling of the
characters and of the story but with
some of the same characters that we've
seen before within the watchmen universe
and he's also said it is definitely not
a Doomsday Clock series as well so this
is gonna be really interesting I think
that could go really well or really
poorly although I will say if you read
the letter that he posted on Instagram
he definitely shows that he understands
the source material and the tone and
even the culture of culture surrounding
this graphic novel this phenomenon
really within the comic universe it is
peppered with references to the graphic
novel
he also says we're gonna get some new
characters so that'll be interesting to
add some new characters to the Watchmen
universe as well one of the things that
as soon as I started reading this letter
that he put on Instagram that made me
laugh and say okay you know what this
guy totally understands the universe
here is he kind of opened with hello I
am the man who is currently defiling
something that you love and let me tell
you more about it like alright well he
knows no matter what
does it's gonna be under a microscope
from all of the comic fans so I'm hoping
that this does show that he understands
the tone the intention really behind the
Watchmen comics and is going to stay
true to that in the series while still
telling his own unique story because he
obviously has some reverence for the
source material so hopefully that's
going to go well in other news this week
with solo coming out
we got the announcement that Boba Fett
is also getting his own standalone movie
which why that's that's my question for
that I I like Boba Fett he's an
interesting character
but we kind of already know his
backstory we already know how he got to
be where he is we already know he's a
clone we already know so much about him
and part of his appeal is that we don't
know much about him so I'm really I just
don't think this is going to be a great
addition to the universe the only hope
the only hope that I have is that this
is going to be written and directed by
James Mangold who also wrote and
directed Logan so maybe maybe we'll get
a really cool badass Boba Fett movie or
maybe it's just gonna be unnecessary and
boring we'll just have to wait and see
because there is no news at all about
when this is gonna start filming or who
is even gonna be cast as Boba Fett so we
got a long time to pick apart the news
on this but my main question is why why
are we doing this everyone just cuz we
can I don't know also this week we got
our first look at Matt Groening 's new
animated series called disenchantment
and it sounds like he's gonna be doing
to the fantasy world with this what he
did went to the sci-fi world with
Futurama so I think it sounds pretty
interesting it follows a princess who is
decided that being a princess and ruling
Kingdom is boring so instead she goes on
an adventure with a demon and an elf who
is
I'll absolutely named elf oh um
throughout this fantasy land and the
pictures that they released really show
exactly what I would have expected the
princess is surrounded by beer Burnley
apparently she is a heavy drinker common
theme I guess oh man some of Matt
grannies work seems like maybe a bender
type character which alright sure let's
do it um and that's actually coming out
on Netflix in August and it's going to
be a 10 episode series the first season
is just 10 episodes I'm sure they're
kind of waiting to see exactly how it's
going to be received by the fans before
they start moving on but if it's
anything like like Futurama I'm excited
for it I'm ready for it and in fact
there's going to be a couple of Futurama
alumni who will be adding their voices
to the cast including John DiMaggio and
Billy West they're not gonna be playing
the bleeds but they're gonna be in there
at some point so again that comes out on
August 14th on Netflix lastly there was
some news this week that the expanse the
sci-fi show that was dropped last week
has been picked up by Amazon for a
season four and fans are very excited
about it I've heard that it's a great
sci-fi show personally I haven't watched
it but I saw that there was a lot of
people really rallying around this show
so it's exciting it's gonna be moving
onto Amazon and this is not the end of
the expanse so good job fans you got
another show picked up by a new new
network in order to keep it running so
nice work fans that's gonna be it for me
this week feel free to continue the
conversation with me on social media you
can find me on Twitter at Heather ruse
Instagram at a truce or twitch twitch TV
slash Heather Roose where I stream on
Wednesday nights let me know in the
comments below any casting news that we
missed or any other news that you want
to talk about until next week beam me up
[Applause]
you